The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So, let's get started.
Why doesn't everyone take 10
more seconds to answer this
clicker question here.
All right.
So, good.
It looks like just about
everyone is able to go from
the name of an orbital to
the state function.
That's important.
And we're actually going to get
a little bit deeper in our
clicker questions here, since
when you do your problem-set
it won't be quite this straight
forward that you'll
be answering this kind of
question, but actually you'll
be thinking about how many
different orbitals can have
certain state functions or
certain orbital names.
So let's go to a second
clicker question
here and try one more.
So why don't you tell me how
many possible orbitals you can
have in a single atom
that have the
following two quantum numbers?
So let's say we have n equals
4, and n sub l equalling
negative 2.
How many different orbitals can
you have that have those
two quantum numbers in them?
And this should look kind of
familiar to some of the
problems you may have seen on
the problem-set if you started
it this weekend.
So this should be something you
can do pretty quickly, so
let's take 10 more
seconds on that.
All right.
OK, looks like we got the
majority, which is a good
start, but we having
discrepancy on
what people are thinking.
So, let's go through this one.
So, what we're saying is that
we have n equals to 4, and m
sub I being equal
to negative 2.
If we have n equals 4, what
is the highest value of
l that we can have?
STUDENT: 3.
PROFESSOR: OK.
We can have n 4, l 3, and then,
sure, we can have m sub
l equal negative 2 if l equals 3
What's the second value of l
that we can have?
2.
OK.
So we can have this
orbital here.
What about l equals 1,
can we have this?
No, we can't.
Because if l equals 1, we can
not have m sub l equal
negative 2, right, because the
magnetic quantum number only
goes from negative l
to positive l here.
So that means it's not possible,
if we've made these
stipulations in the first
place, to have a case
where l equals 1.
So this means we can only have
2 different values of l.
We already know our
value of m.
So now we're just counting up
our orbitals, an orbital is
completely described by
the 3 quantum numbers.
So we end up having
2 orbitals here.
All right, so hopefully if you
see any other combination of
quantum numbers, for example, if
it doesn't quickly come to
you how many orbitals you have,
you can actually try to
write out all the possible
orbitals and that should get
you started.
All right.
So today we're going to finish
up our discussion of the
hydrogen atom.
We'd started on Monday talking
about radial probability
distributions for
the s orbitals.
We'll finish that up, and then
we're going to move on to
talking about the p orbitals.
We'll start with talking about
the shape, just like we did
with the s orbitals, and then
move on to those radial
probability distributions and
compare the radial probability
at different radius for p
orbital versus an s orbital.
And once we do that, we're
actually going to move on to
multi-electron atoms.
So, you might have noticed that
we will have spent about
6 and 1/2 lectures just getting
to the point where we
have only one electron, so we're
only up hydrogen so far.
And you might have kind of
been projecting ahead and
thinking if we keep up at this
pace, pretty much we would
only get to carbon by the
end of the semester.
So I will assure you that we
will not be spending 6
lectures per atom as we move
forward, and in fact, what
we're going to find is that by
taking all the principles
we've learned about the hydrogen
atom and applying
that to multi-electron atoms,
but making a few of changes
and making a few modifications
to take into the fact that
we're going to have
electron-electron repulsions
going on, we'll be able to think
about any multi-electron
atom using these same general
ideas, and the Schrodinger
equation ideas that we came up
with and have looked at for
the hydrogen atom.
And this is really good news
because it's good to get
passed carbon.
I'm an organic chemist, so I
love carbon, it's one of my
favorite atoms to talk about,
but it would be nice to get to
the point of bonding and even
reactions to talk about all
the exciting things we
can think about once
we're at that point.
So, one we finish our discussion
of how we think
about multi-electron atoms, we
can go right on and start
talking about these
other things.
All right.
So, let's pick up where we left
off, first of all we're
still on the hydrogen
atom from Monday.
And on Monday what we were
discussing was the solution to
the Schrodinger equation
for the wave function.
And we also, when we solved or
we looked at the solution to
that Schrodinger equation,
what we saw was that we
actually needed three different
quantum numbers to
fully describe the wave function
of a hydrogen atom or
to fully describe an orbital.
We didn't just need that n, not
just the principle quantum
number that we needed to discuss
the energy, but we
also need to talk about l and
m, as we did in our clicker
question up here.
We also talked about well, what
is that when we say wave
function, what does that
actually mean?
And first we discussed the fact
that well, in terms of a
classical analogy, we don't
really have one for wave
function, we can't really think
of a way to picture wave
function thinking in classical
terms. But we do have an
interpretation for wave
function squared.
And when we take the wave
function and square it, that's
going to be equal to the
probability density of finding
an electron at some point
in your atom.
And that's useful in terms of
seeing a general shape, but if
we're actually interested in
thinking about how far away
that electron is from the
nucleus, you can see that
instead of talking about
probability density, which is
the probability per volume,
instead it would be much more
useful to talk about something
called radial probability
distribution, or in other
words talking about the
probability of finding the
electron at some distance,
which we define as r, from the
nucleus in a spherical shell
that is just infinitesimally
small, infinitesimally thin at
distance or at a thickness that
we'll call a d r here.
So, basically what we're saying
is if we take any shell
that's at some distance away
from the nucleus, we can think
about what the probability is of
finding an electron at that
radius, and that's the
definition we gave to the
radial probability
distribution.
And we can look at the formula
that got us here.
This is the radial probability
distribution formula for an s
orbital, which is, of course,
dealing with something that's
spherically symmetrical.
It's somewhat different when
we're talking about the p or
the d orbitals, and we won't
go into the equation there,
but this will give you an idea
of what we're really talking
about with this radial
probability distribution.
So, what we can do to actually
get a probability instead of a
probability density that we're
talking about is to take the
wave function squared, which
we know is probability
density, and multiply it by the
volume of that very, very
thin spherical shell that
we're talking about at
distance r.
So if we want to talk about the
volume of that, we just
talk about the surface area,
which is 4 pi r squared, and
we multiply that by
the thickness d r.
So if we take this term, which
is a volume term, and multiply
it by probability over volume,
what we're going to end up
with is an actual probability
of finding our electron at
that distance, r, from
the nucleus.
So, the example that we took
on Monday and that we ended
with when we ended class, was
looking at the 1 s orbital for
hydrogen atom, and what we could
do is we could graph the
radial probability as a function
of radius here.
And when we do that we can see
this curve, this probability
curve, where we have a maximum
probability of finding the
electron this far away
from the nucleus.
And we call that most probable
radius r sub m p, or most
probable radius.
And what is discussed is that
for a 1 s hydrogen atom, that
falls at an a nought distance
away from the nucleus.
And remember, a nought, that's
just the Bohr radius, it's a
constant -- that's all we
need to worry about.
We talked about the Bohr
model and how that
told us an exact distance.
It was a classical model, right,
so we could say the
electron is exactly this far
away from the nucleus.
We can not do that with quantum
mechanics, the more
true picture is the best we can
get to is talk about what
the probability is of
finding the electron
at any given nucleus.
And the most probable one
here is that a nought.
The other thing that we looked
at, which I want to stress
again and I'll stress it as
many times as I can fit it
into lecture, because this is
something that confuses
students when they're trying
to identify, for example,
different nodes or areas
of no probability.
In an orbital is remember that
this area right here at r
equals zerio, that
is not a node.
We will always have r equals
zero in these radial
probability distribution graphs,
and we can think about
why that is.
At first it might be
counter-intuitive because we
know the probability density
at the nucleus is the
greatest. So the probability of
having an electron at the
nucleus in terms of probability
per volume is
very, very high.
But remember that we need to
multiply it by the volume
here, the volume of some
sphere we've defined.
And when we define that as
r being equal to zero,
essentially we're
multiplying the
probability density by zero.
So that's why we have this zero
point here, and just to
point out again and again and
again, it's not a radial node,
it's just a point where we're
starting our graph, because
we're multiplying it
by r equals zero.
So, we can look at other
radial probability
distributions of other
wave functions
that we talked about.
We talked about the wave
function for a 2 s orbital,
and also for a 3 s orbital.
So, let's go ahead and think
about drawing what that would
look like in terms of the
radial probability
distribution.
So what we're graphing here is
the radius as a function of
radial probability.
And for a 2 s orbital, you get
a graph that's going to look
something like this.
So, again, we're starting
at zero.
We have one node here, and we
can again define that most
probable radius.
And it turns out that for a 2
s orbital, that's equal to 6
times a nought.
So when we think about what
it is that this radial
probability distribution is
telling us, it's telling us
that it is most likely that an
electron in a 2 s orbital of
hydrogen is six times further
away from the nucleus than it
is in a 1 s orbital.
So another way to say that is,
in a sense, if we're thinking
about the excited state of a
hydrogen atom, the first
excited state, or the n equals
2 state, what we're saying is
that it's actually bigger than
the ground state, or the 1 s
state of a hydrogen atom.
And when we say bigger,
remember this is not a
classical description
we're talking about.
We are talking about
probability, but what we're
saying is that most probable
radius is further away from
the nucleus.
So we can also look at this in
terms of the 3 s orbital.
And in this case, we have
a graph that looks
something like this.
So you can draw that
into your notes.
And again, we can define what
that most probable radius is,
that distance at which
we're most
likely to find an electron.
And in the case of the 3 s
orbital, that's going to be
equal to 11 .
5 times a nought.
So again, what we're saying here
is that it is most likely
in the 3 s orbital that we would
find the electron 11 and
1/2 times further away from the
nucleus than we would in a
around state hydrogen atom.
And I just want to point out
here in terms of things that
you're responsible for, you
should know that the most
probable radius for
a 1 s hydrogen
atom is equal a nought.
And you should know that a 2 s
is larger than that, and a 3 s
is even larger, and of course,
hopefully as we go to 4 and 5,
you would be able to guess that
those are going to get
even larger.
But you're not responsible
for knowing specifically
that it's 11 .
5 times greater.
You just need to know
the trend there.
Another thing to point out in
these two graphs is that we do
have nodes, and we figured out
last time, we calculated how
many nodes we should have
in a 2 s orbital.
And in terms of radial nodes,
we expect to see one node.
And how many nodes do you see in
the 3 s orbital? two, good.
I'm glad to hear that no
one counted this r
equal zero as a node.
So we expect to see two nodes
right here in the 3 s orbital.
And we can calculate that with
the formula that we used,
which was just n minus l minus
1 equals the number of nodes.
Or we could just look at
the radial probability
distribution itself and see
how many nodes there are.
So if we're looking at these two
situations here and we're
actually thinking of them from
a more classical standpoint,
which is natural for us to do
because we live our lives in
the every day world, not
thinking about things on the
atomic size scale all the
time, most of us.
So, for example, if we were to
look at this 3 s orbital here,
you might have the question of
how this can be, because we're
saying that, for example, we
have probability of having an
electron here, an electron
can also be way out
at this radius here.
But what we're saying is there's
a node here, so that
there's no probability of
finding an electron between
those two points.
So you can think of it, if we
were to just think of it as a
straight line that we were going
across, essentially what
we're saying is that we're
getting from point a to point
c without ever getting
through point b.
So, that can be a little bit
confusing for us to think
about, and when it's a very good
question you might, in
fact, say well, maybe there's
not zero probability here,
maybe it's just this teeny,
teeny, tiny number, and in
fact, sometimes an electron
can get through, it's just
very low probability so that's
why we never really see it.
And in fact, that's
not the answer.
The answer is, in fact, there
is zero, absolutely zero
probability of finding
a electron here.
So basically we're saying yes,
we can go from point a to
point c without ever going
through point b.
That might seem confusing
if you're thinking about
particles, but remember we're
talking about the wave-like
nature of electrons.
So, the quantum mechanical
interpretation is that we can,
in fact, have probability
density here and probability
density there, without having
any probability of having the
electron in the space between.
And you can think about that if
you think about a standing
wave, for example, where you
can have amplitude at many
different values of x, so an
amplitude at many different
distances, but you also
have areas where
there is a 0 amplitude.
So, remember this makes sense
if you just think of it as a
wave and forget the particle
part of it for right now,
because that would be very
upsetting to think about and
that's not, in fact, what's
going on, we're talking about
quantum mechanics here.
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, I'm sorry.
So it's n minus l minus 1.
So here we have 3 minus l equals
0, because it's an s
orbital, minus 1, so we have
two radial nodes here.
OK.
So let's actually go to a
clicker question now on radial
probability distributions.
So I mentioned you should be
able to identify both how many
nodes you have and what a
graph might look like of
different radial probability
distributions.
So here, what I'd like you to
do is identify the correct
radial probability distribution
plot for a 5 s
orbital, and also make sure that
it matches up with the
right number of radial nodes
that you would expect.
All right.
Let's take 10 more seconds on
that, this should be a quick
identification for us to do.
All right.
So it looks like 82% got the
correct answer here.
So, you should know that there's
four radial nodes,
right, we have 5 minus 1 minus
l -- is there a question?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It is very difficult
for me to draw
graphs on the computer.
That's a good point,
I'm sorry.
This was my best attempt at
hitting zero and not having
the graph go down there.
I'm not the most gifted at
drawing on the computer.
So yes, it should be zero
at zero, but I made
the line too thick.
So, assuming -- if anyone got
it wrong because of that,
that's my apologies,
that's my fault.
But you should see that there
are four radial nodes here
since we have a 5 s orbital.
And also that we know that the
zero does not count as a node,
if per se I actually had managed
to hit zero in drawing
that, so the correct answer
would be the bottom one there.
So, you should be able to
generally identify and draw
the general form of these
radial probability
distributions.
Obviously we don't expect you
to know exactly what the
distances are, but you should
be able to compare them
relatively.
Yes?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No, they actually
don't, and when you
graph it all out.
You can see this if you
look at some examples
in your book, actually.
So this doesn't fall, for
example, at 6 a nought, but
that's a really good question.
And the trend always is that the
probability gets smaller
with each of the peaks as
you're drawing them.
All right.
So we can switch back
to our notes.
So we got our clicker
question set there.
And so now we can move on to
thinking about p orbitals, we
now have two ways to talk
about p orbitals.
We can talk about the wave
function squared, the
probability density, or we
can talk about the radial
probability distribution.
So when we talk about p
orbitals, it's similar to
talking about s orbitals, and
the difference lies, and now
we have a different value for
l, so l equals 1 for a p
orbital, and we know if we have
l equal 1, we can have
three different total orbitals
that have sub-shell of l
equalling 1.
So we can have, if we have the
final quantum number m equal
plus 1 or minus 1, we're
dealing with a
p x or a p y orbital.
Remember, we don't do a
one-to-one correlation,
because p x and p y are some
linear combination of the m
plus 1 and m minus 1 orbital.
And if we talk about
m equals 0, we're
looking at the p z orbital.
And the significant difference
between s orbitals and p
orbitals that comes from the
fact that we do have angular
momentum here in these p
orbitals, is that p orbital
wave functions do, in fact, have
theta and phi dependence.
So they do have an angular
dependence that
we're talking about.
And what I'm showing here is not
on your notes, if you're
interested you can look
it up in your book.
This is a table that's directly
from your book, and
what it's just showing is the
wave function for a bunch of
different orbitals.
I mentioned last time
that there was this
list in your book.
And what I want to point out
here is this angular
dependence for the p orbitals
for the l equals 1 orbital.
So, first, if I point out when
l equals 0, when we have an s
orbital, what you see is that
angular part of the wave
function is equal
to a constant.
So, remember we can break up the
total wave function into
the radial part and
the angular part.
When we look at this angular
part, we see that it's always
the square root of 1 over 4 pi,
it doesn't matter what the
angle is, it's not dependent
on the angle.
In contrast when we're looking
at a p orbital, so any time l
is equal to 1, and you look at
angular part of the wave
function here, what you see is
the wave function either
depends on theta or
is dependent on
both theta and phi.
So we do, in fact, have a
dependence on what the angle
is of the electron as we define
it in the orbital.
So what this means is that
unlike s orbitals, p orbitals
are not spherically symmetrical
-- they don't have
the exact same shape at any
radius from the nucleus.
And these shapes of p orbitals
probably do look familiar to
you, most of you, I'm sure, have
seen some sort of picture
of p orbitals before.
So what I want to point out
about them is that they're
made up of two nodes, and what
you can see is that nodes are
shown in different colors
here and those
are different phases.
Sometimes you see this written
when you see p orbitals, one
is written as plus, one
is written in minus.
That's not a positive and
negative charge, that's
actually a phase, and that
arises from the wave equation.
Remember when we have waves
we can have positive or a
negative amplitude.
When we talk about p orbitals
the phase of the orbital
becomes important once we talk
about bonding, which hopefully
you were happy to hear at
the beginning of class
we will get to soon.
And it turns out that when you
constructively have two p
orbitals interfere, and when I
say constructively, I mean
they're both either positive or
they're both the negative
lobes, that's when
you got bonding.
Whereas if the phases where
mismatched, you
would not get bonding.
So, that's going to be important
later when we get to
bonding, but just take note of
it now, we have two nodes,
each with a separate phase --
or we have two lobes, excuse
me, each with a separate
phase.
And when we look at this, it's
actually split by what's
called a nodal plane, which is
pointed out in light orange
here on this picture, but what
we just mean is that there is
this whole plane that separates
the two lobes where
there is absolutely no
electron density.
So, the wave function at all of
these points in this plane
is equal to zero, so therefore,
also the wave
function squared is going
to be equal to zero.
So, if we say that in this
entire plane we have zero
probability of finding a p
electron anywhere in the
plane, the plane goes directly
through the nucleus in every
case but a p orbital, so what we
can also say is that there
is zero probability of finding
a p electron at the nucleus.
So, again we can use these
probability density plots,
which are just a plot of psi
squared, where the density of
the dots is proportional to the
density, the probability
density, at that point.
So what we can say is look at
each of these separately, so
if we start with looking at the
2 p z orbital, the highest
probability of finding an
electron in the 2 p z orbital,
is going to be along
this z-axis.
We can see that right here.
And in terms of thinking about
the phase of this p orbital,
the phase is going
to be positive
anywhere where z is positive.
So we would say we have a
positive phase here and a
negative phase there.
Remember, that's going to become
important when we talk
about bonding, we don't
need to worry about it
too much right now.
We can also think about where
the nodal plane is in this p z
orbital, so how would we define
the nodal plane here?
What would the nodal plane be?
So, it's the x-y plane, you can
see there's no electron
density anywhere there.
And similarly, actually, if
we're looking at our polar
coordinates here, what we see is
it's any place where theta
is equal to 0 is what's going
to put up on the x-y plane.
So another way to define the
nodal plane is where theta is
equal to 90 degrees.
So let's look now at
the 2 p x orbital.
This is the probability density
map, so we're talking
about the square here.
The highest probability now is
going to be along the x-axis,
so that means we're going to
have a positive wave function
every place where
x is positive.
What is the nodal plane
in this case?
Um-hmm.
So, it's going to be the y z
nodal plane, or in other
words, we can say it's
any place where phi
is equal to 90 degrees.
So you can see if you take phi,
and you move it over 90
degrees, we're right here
in the y z plane.
Anywhere where that's the case
we're going to have no
probability density of
finding an electron.
And finally, we can look at
the 2 p y, so the highest
probability is going to
be along the y-axis.
It's going to be positive in
terms of its wave function or
in terms of its phase anywhere
where y is positive.
And the nodal plane's going to
be in the x z plane, or again,
anywhere where phi is going to
be equal to 0, that takes us
to the x z plane.
So, let me get a little bit more
specific about what we
mean by nodal plane and where
the idea of nodal plane comes
from, and nodal planes arise
from any place you have
angular nodes.
So we talked about radial nodes
when we're doing these
radial probability density
diagrams here.
You can also have angular notes,
and when we talk about
an anglar node, what we're
talking about is values of
theta or values of phi at which
the wave function, and
therefore, the wave function
squared, or the probability
density are going to
be equal to zero.
So, you remember from last time
radial nodes are values
of r at which the wave function
and wave function
squared are zero, so the
difference is now we're just
talking about the angular part
of the wave function.
And, in fact, these are the only
two types of nodes that
we're going to be describing,
so we can actually calculate
both the total number of notes
and the number of each type of
node we should expect to see
in any type of orbital.
And our equation for total nodes
is just the principle
quantum number minus 1.
And when we talk about angular
nodes, the number of angular
nodes we have in an orbital
is going to be equal to l.
So that's why we saw, for
example, in the p orbitals we
had one angular node in each
p orbital, because l
is equal to 1 there.
And we talked about the equation
you can use for
radial nodes last time, and
that's just n minus 1 minus l.
You can go ahead and use that
equation, or you could figure
it out every time, because if
you know the total number of
nodes, and you know the angular
node number, then you
know how many nodes you're
going to have left.
So you don't really have
to memorize that.
So, let's go ahead and just
do a few of these.
They're pretty straight forward
to do and it gives us
an idea what kind of nodal
structure we can
expect it an orbital.
So for a 2 s orbital, how many
total nodes will we have?
Yup, I heard one, so 2 minus
1, one total node.
Angular nodes, we're not going
to have any of those, we'll
have zero, l equals 0, so we
have zero angular nodes.
And in terms of radial nodes, we
have 2 minus 1 minus 0, so
what we have is one
radial node.
So, what you find with the s
orbital, and this is general
for all s orbitals is that all
of your nodes end up being
radial nodes.
That has to be the
case because l
equals 0 for s orbitals.
Let's look now at a p orbital,
so how many total
nodes do we have here?
Yup, so one total node, 2 minus
1 is 1, and that means
since l is equal to 1, we have
one angular nodes, and that
leaves us with how many
radial nodes?
Yup, zero radial nodes.
So, for a 2 p orbital, all the
nodes actually turn out to be
angular nodes.
So, let's have you try one more,
if we can switch over
and talk about a 3 d orbital.
So, I'm asking very specifically
about radial
nodes here, how many radial
nodes does a hydrogen atom 3 d
orbital have?
So, you can go ahead and take
10 seconds on that.
All right.
So most of you got that, though
there is this little
sub-set we have thinking that we
have one, so let's actually
write this out here.
So if we have a 3 d orbital,
we're talking about n minus l
minus 1, what is n equal to?
What is l equal to?
OK. and 1 is equal to 1.
So, it turns out that we have
zero nodes that we're dealing
with when we're talking
about a 3 d orbital.
OK.
So we should be able to figure
this out for any orbital that
we're discussing, and when we
can figure out especially
radial nodes, we have a good
head start on going ahead and
thinking about drawing radial
probability distributions.
We did it for the s orbitals,
we can also do it for the p,
we can do it for the d.
All we have to figure out is how
many nodes we're dealing
with and then we can get
the general shape
of the graph here.
So, let's actually compare
the radial probability
distribution of p orbitals to
what we've already looked at,
which are s orbitals, and we'll
find that we can get
some information out of
comparing these graphs.
So if we draw the 2 p orbital,
what we just figured out was
there should be zero
radial nodes, so
that's what we see here.
The other thing that I want you
to notice, is if you look
at the most probable radius,
for the 2 s orbital it's
actually out further away from
the nucleus than it is for the
2 p orbital.
So what we can say here is that
the 2 p is less than or
smaller than the 2 s orbital.
So think about what that means,
we're, of course, not
talking about this in classical
terms, so what it
means if we have an electron in
the 2 p orbital, it's more
likely, the probability is that
will be closer to the
nucleus than it would be if it
were in the 2 s orbital.
We can also take a look the 3
s, which we have looked at
before, and we figured out
that that should have two
radial nodes.
We can look at the 2 p, which
should have one radial node,
and we just figured it out for
the, excuse me, for the 3 p
has one radial node, and for the
3 d here, we should have
zero radial nodes, we just
calculated that.
So again, what we see is the
same pattern where the most
probable radius, if we talk
about it in terms of the d,
that's going to be smaller then
for the p, and the 3 p
most probable radius is going
to be closer to the nucleus
than it is for the 3 s most
probable radius that we're
looking at.
So, there are 2 different things
that we can compare
when we're comparing graphs
of radial probability
distribution, and the first
thing we can do is think about
well, how does the radius
change, or the most probable
radius change when we're
increasing n, when we're
increasing the principle
quantum number here?
So, from going from the shell
of n equals 2, let's say, to
the shell of n equals 3.
And what we find is we're going
from about or exactly a
6 a nought here, to almost three
times that when we're
going from 2 s to 3 s.
So we say if n increases,
the orbital size is
also going to increase.
And when we talk about size,
I'm again just going to say
the stipulation that we're
talking about, probability --
we're not talking about an
absolute classical concept
here, but in general we're going
to picture it being much
further away from the nucleus
as we move up in terms of n.
The other thing that we took
note as is what happens as l
increases, and specifically as
l increases for any given the
principle quantum number.
So if we're keeping n the same,
we look and what we saw
was that size actually decreases
as we increase the
value of l.
So, I want to contrast that
with another concept that
seemed to be opposing ideas, and
that is thinking about not
how far away the most probable
radius is, but thinking about
how close an electron can get
to the nucleus if it's
actually in that orbital.
And what we'll find is that we
actually see the opposite.
So if we compare l increasing
here, so a 3 s to a 3 p to a 3
d, what we find is that it's
only in the s orbital that we
have a significant probability
of actually getting very close
to the nucleus.
So, if I kind of circle where
the probability gets somewhat
substantial here, you can see
we're much closer to the
nucleus at the s orbital than we
are for the p, then when we
are for the d.
So, the size still for an s
orbital is larger than for a d
orbital, but what we say is
that an s electron can
actually penetrate closer
to the nucleus.
There's some probability that
it can get very, very close
the nucleus, and that
probability is actually
substantial.
A kind of consequence of this
is if we're thinking about a
multi-electron atom, which we'll
get to in a minute where
electrons can shield each other
from the pull of the
nucleus, we're going to say that
the electrons in the s
orbitals are actually
the least shielded.
And the reason that they're the
least sheilded is because
they can get closest to the
nucleus, so we can think of
them as not getting blocked by
a bunch of other electron,
because there's some probability
that they can
actually work their way all
the way in to the nucleus.
So, this is a concept
that's going to
become really important.
Soon when we're talking about
multi-electron atoms, and I
just want to introduce it
here, that it is sort of
opposing ideas that even though
the s is the biggest
and it's most likely that the
electron's going to be
furthest away from the nucleus,
that's also the
orbital in which the electron
can, in fact, penetrate
closest.
All right.
So I think we are, in fact,
ready to move on to
multi-electron atoms, and what
happens is when we solved the
relativistic version of the
Schrodinger equation and we're
discussing more than one
electron, we actually have a
fourth quantum number that falls
out and that we need to
deal with and this is
called the electron
spin quantum number.
And I promise, this is the last
quantum number that we'll
be introducing.
And this spin magnetic quantum
number we abbreviate as m sub
s, so that's to differentiate
from m sub l.
And when you solved the
relativistic form of the
Schrodinger equation, what you
end up with is that you can
have two possible values
for the magnetic
spin quantum number.
You can have it equal to plus
1/2, and that's what we call
spin up, or you can have it
equal to minus 1/2, which is
what we call spin down.
So, there's two kind of cartoons
shown here that give
you a little bit of an idea
of what this quantum
number tells us.
And this spin is an intrinsic
quality of the electron, it's
a property that is intrinsic in
all particles, just like we
would say mass is intrinsic
or charge is intrinsic.
Spin is also an intrinsic
property.
One way to think about it, if
we want to use a classical
analogy, which often helps to
give us an idea of what's
going on, is the spin of an
electron, we can picture it
rotating on its own axis.
So that's kind of what's shown
in these pictures here.
So you can see, if it's spinning
on its own axis in
this direction we'd call it spin
up, where as this way it
would be what we
call spin down.
So, it turns out there's not
actually a good classical
analogy for spin, we can't
really think of it like that,
but if that helps give you an
idea of what's going on here
then it's valuable maybe to
consider it spinning on its
own axis, even though that's not
technically what's exactly
happening here.
But the reason that I like that
analogy is that it points
out a very important part of
spin, and that's the idea that
it's a description
of the electron.
It is not dependent on
the actual orbital.
So we can completely describe
an orbital with just using
three quantum numbers, but we
have this fourth quantum
number that describes something
about the electron
that's required for now a
complete description of the
electron, and that's
the idea of spin.
So, we need to actually add on
this fourth quantum number,
and it's either going to be
plus 1/2 or negative 1/2.
So, we can talk a little bit
actually, because it's an
interesting story about where
the idea of spin came from,
and it was actually first
proposed by two very young
scientists at the time, George
Uhlenbeck shown here, and
Samuel Goudsmit who's here, and
they're with a friend, and
I can't remember who that is,
but he did not have anything
to do with discovering spin.
And what you can see in this
picture is that these are
actually, they're pretty young
guys in this picture.
I think this is taken about
two years after they
discovered the fourth
quantum number.
So hopefully, you can picture
yourself at this age in a
similar situation with an
anonymous friend and think
this is something, kind of
observations maybe you can
make as well.
And what they were doing when
they discovered that there
must be this fourth quantum
number is they were looking at
the emission spectrum of sodium,
and, so specifically,
they were looking at the
frequencies, and if we think
about the frequencies of sodium,
it was already known
at this time that you could
calculate what those would be
based on the difference in the
energy levels -- this happened
in about 1925.
So they actually knew exactly
what they were expecting.
So, let's say they were
expecting to see one certain
frequency or one line in the
spectrum at this point here.
It turns out that what they
actually observed, so this is
the actual of what they saw,
is if they were expecting
their line at some given
frequency, which I'll show by
this dotted line here, what
they actually saw was two
lines, and one was just the
teeniest tiniest bit of a
higher frequency than what was
expected, and one was just,
just below what they expected.
And if we're talking about
things in spectroscopy terms
here, this is what we
call a doublet.
So it's centered at this
frequency that was expected,
but it's actually split into
two different frequencies.
And this was an amazing
observation that they made.
They were totally surprised
and excited, and they were
thinking how could this happen,
where did we got this
split doublet from.
And what they could come up
with, what they reasoned, is
that there must be some
intrinsic property within the
electron, because we know that
this describes the complete
energy of the orbital should
give us one single frequency.
And that the fact that it split
into two was telling
them that there must be some new
property to the electron,
and what we call that
now is either being
spin up or spin down.
But at the time, they didn't
have a well-formed name for
it, they were just saying OK,
there's this fourth quantum
number, there's this intrinsic
property in the electron.
So, where the story gets kind
of unfortunate, but also a
little bit more interesting is
the fact that well, they did
publish what they observed, and
they did write that up.
They put it in a pretty
low impact paper.
I think it was in French, so it
wasn't really hitting all
the scientific community of
the time in any major way.
And they didn't put their
explanation of what they
thought was going on,
it just sort of was
observing what they saw.
These were very young
scientists, of course, so what
you would expect that they would
do, which makes sense,
is go to someone more
established in their field,
because they have the
completely radical
revolutionary idea, let's just
run it by someone before we go
ahead and publish this paper
that makes this huge statement
about this fourth
quantum number.
So the person they chose to talk
to, and I think it was
just Goudsmit that went to him
and discussed it is Wolfgang
Pauli, which is shown here.
So how many before five
minutes ago had
heard the name Goudsmit?
All right, a couple.
OK, cool.
How about Pauli, like the Pauli
exclusion principle?
Hmm, OK.
So, Pauli seems to be getting
a little bit of fame that
you'll see in a second here.
So, it turns out they go and
they discuss their idea with
Pauli, and what Pauli tells
them is that this idea is
ridiculous, that it's rubbish,
if they go ahead and try to
publish this their scientific
careers are ruined.
They can pretty much pack it
up and go home, because
everyone's going to think
they're ridiculous, no one
will believe what they say, and
it's a stupid idea anyway,
is basically the gist of
this conversation.
And in chemistry, just like in
any discipline, you have all
types of scientists, but also
all types of personalities,
and unfortunately Pauli had a
personality that was known
for, first of all, being very
arrogant, but also the very
unfortunate trait of taking
other people's scientific
ideas as his own.
And as the story goes, as
Goudsmit was leaving and the
door with slamming, Wolfgang
Pauli was already writing down
this idea into a scientific
paper of the idea of a fourth
quantum number.
And, in fact, he did make some
more strides, he was a
brilliant thinker, maybe he put
it more articulately than
those two younger scientists
could have. But now, it has
come to light that they are the
ones that do get credit
for first really coming up
with this idea of a spin
quantum number, and it's
interesting to think about how
the politics work in different
discoveries, as well as the
discoveries themselves.
You see that a lot with Nobel
prizes, there's usually a nice
little scandal, a nice little
interesting story behind who
else was responsible for the
Nobel Prize-worthy discovery.
So, here, Pauli came out on top,
we say, and he's known
for the Pauli exclusion
principle, which tells us that
no two electrons in the same
atom can have the same four
quantum numbers.
So let's just think exactly
what this means, and that
means that if we take away
function and we define it in
terms of n, l and m sub l, what
we're defining here is
the complete description
of an orbital.
In contrast, if we're taking
the wave function and
describing it in terms of n, l,
m sub l, and now also, the
spin, what are we
describing here?
An electron.
So now we have the complete
description of an electron
within an orbital.
So, that's an important
distinction to make -- what
three quantum numbers tell us,
versus what the fourth quantum
number can fill in for us
in terms of information.
So what that means is that we're
limited in any atom to
having two electrons per
orbital, right, because for
any orbital we can either have
a spin up electron, a spin
down electron, or both.
So, if we look at neon just as
an example, neon has ten
electron in it, and once we
look at all the orbitals
written out here, this is
probably a familiar thing for
you to look at, but it's
important to think about why,
in fact, we don't just put all
ten electrons, why wouldn't
they just want to go in that
ground state, that lowest
state, right?
That should be the most stable,
the lowest energy
orbital for it to be in, and the
reason they can't do that
is because of the Pauli
exclusion principle -- the
idea that all of the electrons
have to have a different set
of four quantum numbers, so only
two of them can have the
same set of three quantum
numbers here, because for m
sub s, we're only left
with two options.
So let's try a clicker question
and thinking about
the Pauli exclusion principle.
It might look a little bit
similar to a question we just
saw, but hopefully you'll find
that it is, in fact, not the
same question.
So you can go ahead and take
10 seconds on that.
OK, great.
So, most of you recognize that
there are four different
possibilities of there's four
different electrons that can
have those two quantum
numbers.
Actually the easiest
way is probably to
bring this down here.
And the next highest percentage
of you thought that
we still only had two.
So, remember we solved this
problem earlier in the class,
but we were talking
about orbitals.
So there's two different
orbitals that can have these
three quantum numbers, but if
we're talking about electrons,
we can also talk about m sub s,
so if we have two orbitals,
how many electrons can
we have total?
Yeah.
So we have two orbitals, or four
electrons that can have
that set of quantum numbers.
So you'll notice in your
problem-set, sometimes you're
asked for a number of orbitals
with a set of quantum numbers,
sometimes you're asked for a
number of electrons for a set
of quantum numbers.
So make sure first that you read
the question carefully,
and realize the difference
that is between the two.
So, that's where we'll
end today.
So on Friday, we'll start with
talking about the wave
functions for the multi-electron
atoms.